hola en estos vídeos lo que quiero hacer
es comenzar a hacer un par de problemas
introductorios para que veamos que la
trigonometría en realidad es algo útil
así que comencemos dibujando nuestro
triángulo rectángulo
vamos a decir qué
este de aquí es mi triángulo rectángulo
y ya sé que generalmente los dibujos
derechitos pero en este caso también me
gustaría que aprendieran que el
triángulo no siempre es como lo pintan
pero bueno aquí tengo mi triángulo
rectángulo y voy a suponer que también
sé que la medida de este ángulo de aquí
este ángulo es para cuartos radiales
puede escribir rat como abreviación de
radiales acuérdense los ángulos se
pueden medir en grados o en radiales de
hecho y cuartos en radiales equivale a
45 grados pero bueno supongamos también
que yo sé que este lado aquí la
hipotenusa de mi triángulo acuérdense la
hipotenusa es la que es el lado opuesto
al ángulo recto mide 10 x raíz cuadrada
de 2
es lo que valen hipotenusa y voy a
suponer que me preguntan cuánto vale
este lado de aquí este lado que voy a
llamar a ahora bien veamos qué es lo que
sé y qué es lo que quiero averiguar pues
conozco cuánto mide la hipotenusa de mi
triángulo y conozco cuánto mide este
ángulo vale pi cuartos de radiales y
quiero encontrar este lado del triángulo
ahora este lado si se fijan es el lado
adyacente al ángulo este lado acá
este sería precisamente el lado opuesto
al ángulo porque el ángulo abre hacia
este lado pero esto de aquí el lado a el
amarillo es precisamente el lado
adyacente al ángulo de pi cuartos
radiales ahora bien como podemos
proceder pues qué función
trigonométricas involucra a la
hipotenusa y a el lado adyacente al
ángulo pues de nuevo voy a escribir la
mnemotecnia
así que cuál involucra al lado adyacente
y a la hipotenusa pues precisamente esta
de aquí acá que significa coseno
es igual a adyacente déjenme la escribo
completo adyacente
/ hipotenusa
hipotenusa
de modo que si conozco el coseno de este
ángulo y conozco la longitud de la
hipotenusa podría despejar para
encontrar la longitud de este lado a así
que bien
que me diría esto pues me diría que el
coseno de cuartos radiales
y cuartos radiales
es igual a el cateto adyacente al ángulo
de pi cuartos que sería la longitud del
lado a
sería a entre la longitud de la
hipotenusa la hipotenusa tiene longitud
10 x raíz de 2 eso ya lo sabíamos y es
por raíz de 2
bien entonces si multiplico todo esto
por 10 por raíz de 2 que sucede y es por
face dedos por el coseno depp y cuarto
estaciones es igual a entre 10 por raíz
de dos por 10 por raíz de 2
entonces este 10 por raíz de 2 se
cancela con este y obtengo que 10 por
raíz de 2 por el coseno depp y cuartos
radiales es igual a la longitud de mi
lado
ahora bien quizás estén pensando pues no
ha mejorado la cosa porque cuanto es el
co seno del pi cuartos radiales no tengo
ni idea
cuánto vale es grande es chico quien
sabe realmente nadie se memoriza las
funciones trigonométricas hay algunos
ángulos que son digamos notables
de hecho pi cuartos es uno de ellos pero
en general la gente lo que hace es
consultar su calculadora que tendrían
que checar que esté en radiales aguas o
también pueden hacerlo a la manera
antigua comillas y lo que sería eso
sería ir a una tabla de funciones
trigonométricas y checar cuánto vale
esto pero generalmente cuando les den un
problema de estos les van a decir cuánto
valen las funciones trigonométricas de
los ángulos en cuestión así que yo les
voy a decir que el coste no hay cuartos
radiales es igual a raíz de dos entre
de modo que todo esto se convierte en
10 x raíz de 2
por el coseno de pi cuartos radiales que
les digo vale raíz de 2
entre 2
y eso debe ser igual a a
ahora qué pasa raíz de 26 de 12 2 que se
cancela con el 2 de este denominador por
lo tanto sería igual a 10 unidades este
lado
mide 10
perfecto hagamos otro problema
bien entonces me muevo para abajo
ahí está bien y dibujo otro triángulo
rectángulo vamos a decir que más o menos
algo así
de nuevo les recuerdo que no lo quiero
dibujar derecho para qué
para que estemos seguros de que estamos
entendiendo cómo funcionan las cosas así
que tengo este triángulo y voy a suponer
que yo sé que este ángulo de aquí mide
punto 54 radiales es la media ese ángulo
y voy a suponer que también sé que este
lado del triángulo este lado que estoy
re pintando con amarillo mide qué les
parece 3 mide 3 unidades este lado y
ahora lo que quiero hacer es averiguar
cuánto mide
este otro lado del triángulo ahora quién
es este otro lado es la hipotenusa pues
no porque la hipotenusa siempre es
opuesta al ángulo recto vamos en ángulo
recto abre hacia la hipotenusa así que
la hipotenusa es esto de aquí así que
este lado en realidad sería el lado
adyacente al ángulo y eso es el que
quiero encontrar su longitud este es el
lado adyacente adyacente
al ángulo de punto 54 radiales este lado
de aquí no es el lado opuesto porque el
lado opuesto es este que mide 3 unidades
pero bien entonces qué función
trigonométricas involucra al lado
opuesto déjenme anotó este que vale 3 es
el lado opuesto
este es el lado opuesto y qué función
qué econométrica involucra al lado
opuesto y al lado adyacente a un ángulo
pues de nuevo escribimos xo
cuál de estas tres nos involucra el
cateto opuesto y al cateto adyacente
todas todas y recuerden que quiere decir
todas pues quiere decir que la tangente
es igual a el cateto opuesto entre el
cateto adyacente de modo que voy a
escribir a para denotar la longitud de
el lado adyacente quiero encontrar a
así que de aquí la tangente de
lo escribo con colores la tangente de
0.54 radiantes
sería igual a la longitud del lado
opuesto que es 3
entre la longitud del lado adyacente que
es precisamente lo que quiero encontrar
no sé cuánto vale este lado voy a
escribirlo como a así que si puedo
encontrar cuánto vale esta tangente el
valor de esta función de econométrica
puedo despejar a lo que voy a hacer es
multiplicar todo por a y dividirlo entre
la tangente
es decir voy a escribir todo esto como a
va a ser igual a va a ser igual a 3
/
la tangente del ángulo de 0.54
radiales
así que cuánto es eso pues de nuevo
ustedes y de hecho nadie yo creo sabe
cuánto vale este valor de la tangente de
memoria
de nuevo esto es algo que calcula
utilizando una calculadora o que
consultas en una tabla de funciones
trigonométricas o que te dan como parte
de la formulación del problema yo les
voy a decir de antemano que la tangente
de 0.54 radiales es igual a tres quintos
así que todo eso se convierte en a
va a ser igual a la longitud del lado
opuesto al ángulo que es 3 dividido
entre la tangente de 0.54 radiales que
como les acaba de decir es tres quintos
y cuánto es esto pues esto sería lo
mismo que tres por el inverso de tres
quintos que serían cinco tercios por su
recíproco
de modo que
este 3 cancela este 3 y me queda
simplemente 5 la longitud de este lado
es 5 y bueno una estrategia para
resolver estos problemas la estrategia
que hemos usado es ver qué información
tengo disponible y encontrar utilizando
la mnemotecnia soca toda que función
trigonométricas me sirve dados los datos
que ya tengo en el problema otra cosa
que es muy importante tener en mente es
que la definición de soca tohá para las
funciones trigonométricas sólo funciona
cuando estamos utilizando triángulos
rectángulos así que eso es esencial para
poder resolver estos problemas del modo
en el que lo hemos hecho hasta ahora
pero bueno espero esto les haya
resultado interesante